foreign
[Music]
strange trip it's been
it's true
next month marks 10 years of this
YouTube channel of me doing this not 10
years of me doing it professionally not
10 years of me even doing it in this
format but 10 years of this channel
existing
which is
I I don't even know what that is that's
absurd that's amazing that's ridiculous
that's confounding
that's wonderful
10 years
10 years of me sharing in some way shape
or form my thoughts on geeky media
whether it be through scripted shorts
way back in the day whether it be
through conversations with people who
have not appeared on the channel in
years for no reason other than the
logistics have just become a nightmare
at this point to just me rambling at the
camera to me not
looking as I do now to me presenting
however I feel and not worrying about it
anymore
to eventually
be getting to do this for my living
now that part's been going on for a
little bit over two years but yeah 10
years I need to do something for this
because I don't normally Mark the
occasion of anniversaries of this
channel I've marked the occasion of
certain subscriber Milestones uh once at
least maybe twice I can't even remember
but I've never really done the
anniversary theme before but 10 years
that's too big a number to ignore
so what I am planning to do are a couple
of things
uh well a couple of main things anyways
the first is that later in the month of
September so this coming month when the
actual anniversary is because that's how
time works I will be releasing the
complete-ish history of Council of Geeks
talking about how the channel came to be
what it was originally envisioned as the
ways that it has changed over the years
things that I tried that I wish had done
better things that I tried that I'm glad
I stopped doing the evolution of the
channel the evolution of me and the
evolution of this community so that'll
be coming up but in addition to that I
am going to be doing a q a but partly
out of logistical reasons for the amount
of subscribers I have at this point I
can't just do a general q a it's it's
too big it would be too long it would
take forever so what I'm going to do
instead is I am going to be doing a
patreon exclusive q a so if that is
something you wish to participate in
either to be able to ask me a question
or even just to see what my answers are
for other people
tomorrow on September 1st I'm going to
be putting up a post in the patreon for
the patrons saying what questions would
you like me to answer that will be open
for a week after which I will close the
questions and then I will put out a
video for the folks there to answer it
so if that's something you want to
participate with
the patreon is going to be the way to do
that but it's something you'll be able
to do at any support level
and
more than anything
the fact that I am still doing this
10 years on
a decade older
at 40.
the fact that I'm even still doing this
much less that
this is my job
this is what I do for a living
this is what I get to sit down and think
about what I want to do work on how I'm
going to approach it
and do something that used to be what I
do for fun is now my job
that hasn't stopped being amazing in the
last two years and it has made the last
10
feel well I was gonna say worth it they
were worth it even at the time but it
makes those 10 feel like
it was really building to something that
means a lot to me
I've this channel isn't everything that
I do
but this channel contains the most of me
the most stuff I've ever done is all
here
10 years worth with video uploads
ranging from a couple a month to I had a
stretch of time where I was doing one
every day over a thousand video well
over at this point a thousand videos on
this channel and 10 years worth of time
so yeah we're gonna celebrate a little
bit next month
and uh I'm a uh allow myself to um
celebrate a little bit on the uh on the
live stream next month at least one of
them
because it's been 10 years
and while the channel may not be uh old
enough to drink I am
but
in any case
whether you have been here for 10 years
whether you've been here for a week
if you're seeing this video
thank you
thank you for
keeping this whole thing going
and I'm not stopping anytime soon
so as of next month 10 years
of Council of Geeks
thank you so much and never ever forget
you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved you are the council I am
just the one privileged enough to get to
run the meetings
and until next time
this Council this nearly 10 year old
Council
is adjourned
[Music]
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
Robin Moore Zubin lutfola to rock the
thing that goes doink in the anime
Oliver B Linda Walters imudelki theotha
Boyd Becky Sparks fernabe likes the
poodle Zach eidolin Tracy Scrabble angry
Casper Adam RDL Taylor Shane Ross Shayla
gourlay Brendan Larose and TT
[Music]
if you want your name said while these
guys try and distract me
consider looking at the rewards on my
patreon
[Music]